now before we go grab the tissues denzel  washington stop by the late show with  stephen colbert and shed a few tears  while discussing his mother lennis  washington who passed away in june at  the age of 97. take a look  a mother  is a son's  first true love  a son  especially that first son is a mother's  last true love  that's  i'm getting choked up  sorry  ah  but  you know she was there for everything  and uh she went home  i got a tissue  i gotta oh you got a tissue for it there  you go there you go here's your mother  this is the 1990 academy awards  best sporting actor for glory  [Music]  this is terrible  and and  didn't didn't quiet a funeral  why do you think i don't know i i guess  i saved it up for use